[Música]
escuché hace unos minutos a los chicos
del staff decir que poner en marcha este
evento era imposible y lo han hecho
yo quiero invitarles a que sigan
planteándose estos sueños que parecen
imposibles y que sigan trabajando de
forma imparable para hacerlo realidad
precisamente hoy hace 16 años estuve
parado en un pequeño barco pesquero la
costa de esmeraldas eran como las 5 de
la tarde
lloviznaba estaba nublado con lágrimas
de los ojos y con una tristeza
embargada mi alma tuve que cumplir a mi
madre su último deseo y esparcir sus
cenizas en el océano pacifico estaba
devastado
el agua parecía indiferente las disolvía
las cenizas de mi madre indiferente al
hecho de que ella tenía tan sólo 43 años
y yo 19 al agua no le importó que ella
haya muerto de manera violenta y
dolorosa y después de un año el
diagnóstico médico mi madre ya no estaba
y entonces mi vida cambió para siempre
mientras el mar se llevaba las cenizas
de mi madre mi vida parecía pequeña e
insignificante y yo me preguntaba qué va
a pasar de mi a futuro en mi dolor
decidí mirar al horizonte
y comprometerme en transformar el dolor
en oportunidades y decidí luchar contra
este enemigo silencioso este enemigo que
aparece sin avisar parece que no hay
límites para el cáncer o los días
aleatorios cuando llega y se roba a
nuestros seres queridos a nuestros
amigos y a nuestros conocidos
después de dos años regresé al mar
volvía a pararme en este barco pesquero
me había tardado ese tiempo en
recuperarme tuve la visión de poder
hacer algo por los presidentes con
cáncer a futuro van a tener a su mano
las herramientas para poder luchar
contra esta enfermedad con mayor
dignidad y progresivamente comencé a
distinguir fallas de los programas
públicos indiferencia de las empresas
privadas y debilidad en las buenas
intenciones de las organizaciones
sociales y bueno este es un dibujo que
hice hace 10 años
concebía la posibilidad de crear este
espacio ideal para que los niños con
cáncer y sus familias puedan tener a la
mano las herramientas que ellos
necesitan para luchar contra esta
enfermedad con la mayor dignidad
amabilidad humor y amor posible en los
próximos minutos
yo voy a compartir con ustedes tres
ideas que creo que son fundamentales
para convertirnos en imparables y poder
hacerle frente a la injusticia al dolor
a la discriminación que afecta a cientos
de miles de ecuatorianos
yo espero poder transmitirles la misma
determinación feroz que sentido yo desde
aquel día en el que bote las cenizas de
mi madre en el mar
la primera idea es empezar pequeño
pensando en grande como estudiante
universitario con 19 años o con recursos
en los bolsillos yo me preguntaba cómo
voy a ser capaz de generar un cambio
positivo en la vida de las familias con
cáncer cómo voy a hacer un impacto en mi
comunidad decidí ir al hospital donde mi
madre recibía tratamiento
en el vestíbulo y vi a un niño con
cáncer el niño
tenía miedo tenía dolor estaba triste y
no entendía en realidad lo que estaba
sucediendo
su madre conversaba con con otra señora
una señora con cáncer y de necesidad
enfermedad es tan dura es tan dolorosa
que hay días que ni siquiera tenemos 25
centavos para tomar el bus de llegar al
hospital fue precisamente ahí donde tuve
el insight voy a dedicarme en niños y no
solamente en niños sino en toda la
familia toda la familia sufre pero cómo
hacerlo si soy un joven estudiante con
unos pocos amigos así que decidí motivar
a mis amigos
y mis amigos a su vez decidí decidieron
motivar a sus amigos y sus amigos a sus
amigos hasta el día de hoy que nos hemos
convertido en una red de 20.000 amigos
somos la organización de voluntariado
juvenil más grande y mejor organizada de
todo el país
comenzamos de a poco intentando llevar
alegría a los niños de los hospitales y
luego salió la idea de llevar payasos
hospitalarios lo que me llevó a patch
adams
trajimos la patch adams al ecuador
varias veces y esto finalmente me lleva
a la conclusión de que empezar con cosas
simples y sencillas finalmente te lleva
a cosas grandes
desde que libere las cenizas de mi madre
en el mar y cumplido más de 500 sueños a
niños con cáncer sueños muy sencillos
como una bicicleta aprender a nadar
hasta quizás sueños de un poco más
grandes como conocer a shakira justin
bieber ir a un mundial un partido de la
champions e ir a europa e ir a disney
era las princesas la fundación cece la
roda neira ha logrado crear una
microempresa el día de hoy tenemos un
producto que se llama aguayo que lo
distribuimos en varias partes y
generamos 12 fuentes de empleo a madres
de niños con cáncer hemos liderado la
primera investigación sobre la
problemática económica social y emoción
emocional de las familias afectadas por
el cáncer desarrollando un proyecto un
conocimiento profundo sobre nuestras
familias
hemos logrado firmar un convenio con
probablemente el equipo de fútbol más
prestigioso del mundo que es el real
madrid y tenemos en alianza con el real
madrid
primera escuela sociodeportiva para los
hermanos de los niños con cáncer que
beneficia a medio centenar de familias
afectadas por el cáncer y bueno la
escuela granja ese dibujo que yo lo hice
hace hace diez años hoy por hoy es una
realidad un proyecto colaborativo el
municipio quitó nos entregó un terreno
en comodato miles de voluntarios
salieron en colectas públicas durante
tres años con chalecos naranjas
ahorramos cerca de 400 mil dólares de
todas estas colectas invertimos en la
construcción de este proyecto logramos
que más de 70 empresas se sumen en este
proyecto y hoy por hoy la escuela granja
ha generado bienestar a cientos de
familias a través de sus programas
el segundo es este concepto de
adaptarnos y cambiar
desde las islas galápagos de 650 años
hasta silicon valley y el día de hoy
estas palabras atribuidas a charles
darwin yo creo que todavía se mantienen
vigentes y él decía que no es la especie
más fuerte ni la más inteligente la que
sobrevive sino la que mejor se adapta al
cambio y yo creo que es verdad cómo se
darán cuenta no soy la persona más
fuerte tampoco soy la más inteligente y
la pequeña fundación que yo lidero ha
hecho más que sobrevivir
nosotros hemos prosperado porque hemos
comprendido que vivimos en una sociedad
distinta una sociedad que a las
organizaciones sociales vienen
organizadas desde entrega cierto tipo de
poder a través de la revolución del
conocimiento el acceso al big data a las
redes sociales el internet
este tipo de poder que nos permite a los
ciudadanos incluso cambiar las leyes
imagínense un joven de 32 años sentando
a la mesa a todos los candidatos de la
presidencia de la república para que
asuman una
responsabilidad en la lucha integral
contra el cáncer imagínense
un poco antes
haber enviado más de 30 correos al real
madrid antes de recibir una respuesta
tuvieron que pasar dos años hasta que
ellos asumen un compromiso con la
fundación minerva neira yo les puedo
decir que ver a los niños con cáncer de
la fundación cece la rae negra sentados
en el santiago bernabéu viendo un
partido de la champions me hace feliz
30 mails dos años parece nada fácil lo
podemos hacer
y el tercer concepto es este concepto
que yo creo que es fundamental y es de
este concepto de integrarnos en
comunidad
nosotros hemos liderado la creación de
la red nacional de organizaciones de
pacientes de acuerdo contra el cáncer
una iniciativa que llegó a la asamblea
nacional vía democracia directa por
primera vez en el país
yo creo que nos estamos moviendo
rápidamente de ciudadanos que aplican su
responsabilidad en políticos electos a
ciudadanos que los organizamos y
buscamos generar el cambio de forma
directa en nuestra comunidad el día de
hoy los presidentes los congresos los
políticos ya no tienen todo el poder los
ciudadanos bien organizados podemos
cambiar las leyes este cambio de
paradigma de corporaciones grandes y
políticos que hacen las leyes a
organizaciones sociales es una tendencia
que se viene marcando desde hace algunos
años y yo creo y estoy seguro que se va
a seguir fortaleciendo en los próximos
años y esto viene desde este concepto
del autogobierno y yo estoy seguro que
todos los que estamos aquí el día de hoy
podemos unir nuestros esfuerzos y
reconfigurar nuestras miradas para hacer
uso de herramientas modernas de
democracia para poder mejorar incidir en
el bienestar de las familias
lo que más me enorgullece de la
iniciativa acuerdo contra el cáncer es
precisamente el haber sido capaces de
generar mayores expectativas en la vida
de los pacientes con cáncer y además
incentivar a que la ciudadanía sea un
actor activo en la construcción de
soluciones les quiero presentar un
pequeño vídeo de lo que ha sido la
iniciativa popular normativa
para poner en marcha esta iniciativa
ciudadana hemos hecho lo que nunca antes
nadie sacará las leyes de su encierro y
construirlas con la gente
recorriendo todo el país y hemos
recorrido 10 provincias más de 40
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
luchan a diario contra un enemigo
gigante llamado cáncer cada una ha
logrado mucho trabajando por separado
pero ahora han decidido ponerse de
acuerdo en esta causa común
[Música]
hemos estado la amazonía hemos estado en
la sierra hemos estado en la costa hemos
estado en las ciudades hemos estado en
las zonas rurales conociendo los
desafíos que hay alrededor de esta
enfermedad
[Música]
no podría ser
esposa los dos alumnos llamaron a la
quietud
me dijeron que tenía cáncer yo pensé que
para morir no tenía plata y tras el
tratamiento muchas personas pierden las
citas médicas muchas personas pierden
seguimiento de su tratamiento justamente
porque no pueden llegar los hospitales
sumarte a este campaña de los umbrales
[Música]
a la órdenes siempre cuenta con la
institución
yo firmo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
m
[Música]
l
en mi vida
[Música]
i
teníamos aire introduzcan en asumir esta
pequeña de la comunidad de saraguro tuvo
un diagnóstico tardío y mi mamá me hace
estrellar y se infecta más durante
varios meses fue tratada por chamanes
curanderos flotadores entonces me
trajeron para acá cuenca y y aquí en el
seguro dijeron que no tengo un agua lo
que incrementó el dolor no sólo como
ponga y el pro mi pie de hinchar y
cuando finalmente fue derivada a un
hospital ya no había nada que hacer y me
tocó operan y fueron fueron varios meses
de muchísimo dolor hasta llegar al punto
de ser ella misma quien pidió que la
imputa en la pierna y me decidí dijo yo
dije no porque me corté la piel
esta iniciativa popular lo hemos
construido con la gente ya hemos
recorrido el país y hemos nutrido el
proyecto de ley y ya lo hemos entregado
a las máximas autoridades del consejo
nacional electoral
en el pleno del consejo han validado la
iniciativa y nos han entregado los
formularios
[Música]
y nos pueda salir a las calles a pedir
las firmas puestos los chalecos de casa
en casa yo me comprometo a hacerlo
[Música]
i
y
[Música]
somos la buena noticia que el país tanto
necesitaba
[Música]
en estos momentos wilson
[Aplausos]
vuelvo mary 2 ordenador nacional de la
red de acuerdo nacional con 30
[Aplausos]
el gracia con la última canción de las
firmas de respaldo ese proyecto
el día de hoy entregamos 159 mil 876
[Aplausos]
[Música]
una iniciativa que nace desde los
ciudadanos y que está planteando una
forma distinta de hacer las cosas
es que elegimos un grupo de gente
importante que prometen cuando esta
nación nuestro pedido es que se invierte
el orden que se mantenga la estructura y
que se plantee un órgano colegiado como
está establecido en el código orgánico
en la salud que genera una política
pública amplia y que pueda responder a
los anhelos ciudadanos muchas gracias
[Música]
las conquistas que se incorporan en el
código de salud sin duda van a marcar un
antes y un después en la vida de las
familias afectadas por esta enfermedad
se recogen herramientas que van a
permitir que los pacientes con cáncer
tengan esta condición de discapacidad
temporal y ser beneficiados de la ley de
discapacidades se recoge la posibilidad
de que los pacientes con cáncer tengan
herramientas que faciliten el transporte
la estabilidad laboral licencias
laborales para madres de niños con
cáncer se recoge la necesidad de tener
una mirada frente a la salud emocional
de los pequeños se recoge la necesidad
de invertir en investigación social
agradecer a todas las organizaciones
sociales que nos han permitido estar
aquí
si bien la persona visible durante estas
22 sesiones ha sido yo detrás mío hay
más de 18 organizaciones sociales hay
más de 160.000 firmas que han
participado activamente en esta comisión
muchas gracias señor presidente
[Música]
finalmente lo que más me enorgullece de
la iniciativa popular normativa acuerdo
contra el cáncer es del haber sido capaz
de motivar a más de 10.000 jóvenes a
salir a las calles
a salir a las plazas golpear puertas
recoger firmas para promover la igualdad
en la asistencia sanitaria esta
histórica iniciativa popular ya popular
normativa acuerdo contra el cáncer
además inspiró la creación de este
colectivo imparables este colectivo se
ha forjado y que se sigue forjando y que
está planteando una nueva forma de
concebir a la política desde la
participación ciudadana en este sentido
yo creo que los jóvenes tenemos que
asumir un rol mucho más proactivo todos
los que estamos en esta sala somos un
pequeño grupo de jóvenes afortunados que
hemos tenido acceso a educación de
calidad en un país donde la gran mayoría
de jóvenes no tienen ese derecho para
nosotros el participar en democracia
para construir justicia social debe ser
una obligación en este sentido quiero
volver a pedirles que retomemos estas
tres ideas principales creo que para
convertirnos en imparables
empezar pequeños pensando en grande creo
que ese es un objetivo importante cuando
nos planteamos desafíos a largo plazo
creo que es importantísimo cambiar el
dolor transformar el dolor en
oportunidades
el dolor es una constante yo perdí a mi
madre víctima del cáncer generó mucho
dolor pero también perdí a mi padre mi
padre fue secuestrado y brutalmente
asesinado por sus captores eso es una
constante el dolor y los desafíos de la
vida es algo que los seres humanos
tenemos que vivir creo que el gran
mensaje y el gran anhelo es cómo
logramos construir sociedades más
resilientes que sean capaces de
adaptarse a las situaciones difíciles y
cambiar cambiar y construir
oportunidades frente al dolor y el
tercero que yo creo que es fundamental
es integrarnos en comunidad y entender
que nuestra responsabilidad no sólo
puede ser nuestros hijos de nuestra
esposa o nuestros compañeros de la
escuela del colegio de la universidad la
gente de cumbayá la gente de quito
tenemos que abrir nuestra mirada y
entender que vivimos en comunidad que
somos parte de este espacio común
saber en realidad si queremos convivir y
en este sentido abrirnos a la
posibilidad de construir juntos
progresivamente un país de mejores
oportunidades
ahí está frase esta canción muy linda de
esos a que dice
gracias a la desgracia porque me mato
muy mal y seguí cantando y yo quiero
agradecerle a mi madre si le roban era
el día de hoy yo
ahora recuerdo con especial
la recuerdo mucho y se cumplen 16 años
de su muerte
y la verdad es que estoy muy agradecida
porque ella me ha dado un profundo
significado a mi vida un significado que
va mucho más allá de lo que yo soy
[Aplausos]